multiplicar por 10 nos genera un patrón
de números muy ordenado en realidad así
que vamos a tratar de multiplicar
algunos números por 10 y ver si
descubrimos el patrón tratemos de
descubrirlo vamos a empezar con alguno
que tal vez ya no sabemos digamos que
empezaremos con 2 por 10 y tal vez
conocemos la solución pero pensemos más
allá de la solución pensemos en lo que
realmente significa multiplicar 2 por 10
2 por 10 significa que tenemos dos
decenas o que tenemos una decena más
otra decena lo que es igual a 20
tal vez no necesitamos esta parte del
medio tal vez ya sabemos que 2 por 10 es
20 pero será muy útil pensar en lo que
significa 2 por 10 porque eso nos va a
ayudar a resolver algunos problemas que
son más difíciles vamos a intentar con
uno que tal vez es un poco más difícil
vamos a hacer 5 x 10 5 x 10 es igual a 5
decenas o es igual a una decena más otra
decena más una tercera decena más una
cuarta decena más una quinta decena
tenemos cinco decenas uno dos tres
cuatro cinco decenas ahora lo podemos
resolver podemos sumar los 10 20 30 40
50 nuestra solución aquí es 50 5 decenas
o 5 x 10 50
vamos a hacer uno más tal vez uno del
que no conozcamos la respuesta que no
tengamos la respuesta en la mente
intentemos hacer 13 por 10 tal vez no
sabemos la respuesta de multiplicar 13
por 10 pero ahora sabemos que 13 por 10
es 13 decenas y podemos contar 13
decenas tenemos una decena más otra
decena más otra decena 45 6 decenas
7-8 9-10 ya casi llegamos 11 decenas 12
decenas y finalmente 13 decenas vamos a
contar para estar seguros 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12 13 genial entonces tenemos
13 decenas así que vamos a contar las
para ver cuánto suman tenemos 10 20 30
40 50 60 70 80 90 100 110 120 130 la
solución es 130 creo que podemos hacer
pausa aquí y revisar lo que hemos hecho
para ver si podemos descubrir este
patrón 2 por 10 es 20 5 por 10 es 50 13
por 10 el 130 en cada caso tomamos el
número con el que empezamos y lo
apartamos este número es parte de
nuestra respuesta y le agregamos algo
nuevo
agregamos un 0 al final cada vez que
multiplicamos su número por 10 vamos a
dejar el número original y simplemente
le vamos a agregar un 0 al final
entonces intentemos hacer algunos sin
todo esto que tenemos en medio qué tal
si hacemos algo un poco más difícil
digamos 49 por 10 bueno 49 por 10 tal
vez lo imagines va a ser igual a 49 y
que le ponemos al final un 0 490 por que
es igual a 49 decenas y si contamos 49
decenas obtendremos 490 vamos a algo más
difícil que tal si multiplicamos 723 por
10 bueno la solución tal vez ya lo
imaginaste va a ser igual a 723 con un
cero al final o 7230 que es la forma en
que en realidad leemos esta respuesta
pero revisando esto tenemos simplemente
el número original 723 con un cero al
final vamos a dar un paso más adelante y
a pensar en términos de valor posicional
a pensar lo que sucede cuando
multiplicamos 10 en términos de valor
posicional entonces aquí tenemos una
gráfica de valor posicional y vamos a
empezar con un ejemplo simple de los que
hicimos digamos con 2 2 es 2 unidades y
luego multiplicamos ese 2 por 10 y
movemos el 2 una posición y luego
tenemos que llenar este espacio del
valor posicional con un cero así que 2
por 10 es 20 y que pasa en términos del
valor posicional movemos el 2 una
posición de las unidades a las decenas
lo movemos una posición a la izquierda
vamos a revisar otro tal vez uno de los
más difíciles como 723 cuando
multiplicamos 723 por 10 movemos al 7
una posición a la izquierda hacia los
millares el 2 lo movemos hacia las
centenas y movemos el 3 a las decenas
luego una vez más agregamos un 0 en este
espacio vacío del valor posicional así
que podemos describir un patrón al
multiplicar por 10 y es agregar un 0 a
la derecha de todo el número
pero otra manera de describir el patrón
es que cada número se mueve una posición
a la izquierda en su valor posicional
así que si intentamos uno desde este
punto de vista digamos que vamos a
intentar con el 27 si multiplicamos 27
por 10 bueno pues el 2 se va a mover una
posición a la izquierda así que lo
tendremos en las centenas el 7 se va a
mover una posición a la izquierda a las
decenas y luego llenamos la posición
vacía con un 0 entonces podemos decir
que 27 por 10 es igual a 270 así que ya
sea que pensemos en esto como agregar un
cero al final o mover el número una
posición a la izquierda de su valor
posición al multiplicar por 10 genera un
patrón realmente ordenado que podemos
usar para resolver estos problemas